how's it going bros my name is pared
back welcome back to Olaf's Damis demise
I don't know what the guy trust you
what are you doing huh what are you
doing there why are you looking he's
looking at this pole I bet there's a
bomb in it or big I'm just thinking
dildos but I'm sorry that's looking here
all right this empty place why would he
obviously my way somewhere well stop
wasting a lot of the pier that's what
it's trying to say I'm sorry all right I
don't know what I'm sorry for what is
this place really weird map design I
must say it's okay I don't think we can
go here yeah god damn it I need to find
a gay or something
I'm surprised there was no teleporting
naked guys here guys that's the point of
this [ __ ] room all right fair enough
let's check out a done dress all right
could I do trusty now it's okay continue
what hey
oh no why did you do ah no you ate there
oh no he ate her other half that's not
cool that's not cool at all
I can't splash that I kept splash oh you
can't splash in the original get down
I'm sad now all right let's check this
better have something in it hello I
don't like that all right stop wait I
went through a place with that was
filled with fire and as soon as get dark
anyway all right Wow that matter all
right it's fine
this is keep on loading hey Deena Mike
okay we're Tina box what is dance
there's no escape you are trapped here
and now you oh no oh no I have a knife
we'll see about it was gonna die okay I
will die I don't trust you hey beauty I
am so pumped I'm kind of tired today you
know just relaxing kind of show mood but
I'm so freaking puffs anyway what are
you doing with that knife Petey you you
were gonna cut me are you gonna know you
can cut me if you want just you know I
have pretty good bacon you know you want
to eat my bacon okay if there's any pigs
bacon I don't one ate its piggies all
right
that's what are you doing Jesus Christ
are you standing here for five [ __ ]
minutes and you don't even like your
life Jesus Christ
I was talking to piggy and we both
agreed that you should hey what does it
pay more attention when we talk Jesus
Christ pity I am [ __ ] disappointed at
yet alright I need to find a key app
what did I say well they left brick
inside two seconds ago Jesus Christ all
right it's funny I'm sorry and it's good
put you down there
I like a new squad heroin I mean Lydon
and I'm alright we're definitely missing
something here
Davis Christ job will you scare the crap
out of me
go away okay maybe it's the books okay I
know that's but holy [ __ ] there's
something there I'm a genius
god damn it feels good beer
god damn it's just good to be a Stefano
all right you did it pity whatever
anyone could do that
anyone Jesus Christ you think you're so
smart don't all right fine
let's go today out there place what is
this I don't remember this this is a
Stefano
please kind of cool you like it there
spot yes very much you can go in special
right no knocking
it's pretty cozy it's actually hot huh
let's get that Pete alright this guy
don't pee in the pool I would never do I
don't trust him be careful payday I keep
my eye on him alright let's go here may
be some action are you ready I want to
try something if I can open the door
while keeping Stefano in there that'll
be awesome all right you ready one two I
click the door I can't do anything
god damn it good dirt I know what that
was Oh Mike can you hear my share this
is sheriff say you alright let's go here
hey pretty cozy I liked it hey and red
light ah wait wasn't there something
about a red light
oh no ed get out of here I'll see you
later bro ah ah my face Jesus bet that
alright we have his house having the bro
time Jesus Christ Mike oh they have it
why do I know yet Latin Adam all rights
go hey what's a buffer Jesus Christ why
do they always push and what is up for
this door up key no doesn't work
jaysus penis keep going I guess
barrels nope I'm not going to that what
that's gonna Wow I think I have to go
here what if I keep hearing sounds what
is this what is that
it looks like
something
we are friends I'm not gonna touch you I
am gonna touch you however hello I'm
just kidding
oh he's watching the gangbang what's
that he's watching that yeah I did that
hey Jesus why did you why did you do use
it
wait I see something here is there
something Oh No
ah this is disgusting there's a key
between Oh No all right damn that was a
another king prisoner did they do to me
look look look at me won't you see that
backflip that's amazing oh yeah I can do
it
no no no no no no no little little bro
bro today I tried to warn you
Jesus Christ you never [ __ ] list God
I just wanted it like an Iron Maiden I
love bad things crap I keep forgetting
we're like all right there's God prison
key no God I have like five keys
what do you want from me I have three
[ __ ] keys are you serious
no no are you serious yes fine keep
going I guess nice Oh nope
[Music]
ah okay drilled open I don't have a
[ __ ] drill I have three keys though I
don't have a [ __ ] Revell I have their
gear I have your keys betch betch
Patrick kiss fetch Matthew keys why do
you have those things I don't like this
this is found a holder what are you
doing with this Stephano holder and I
trust you either
brother I did nothing
now what about you okay we're good what
are you doing do you talk to me two
barrels I thought we were friends
Jesus Christ fine I'm just gonna go I
don't trust the barrels guys okay
Aladdin Adam
give me the lad nine on him I need the
drugs hey bow
jeez ah more all right Santa
I don't like say any more except for
this place but it's upper barrels my rap
what what I gotta find something what do
you want from me maybe maybe I place the
helmet on the Stefano what about this do
you like that do you like that do you
like that who should I talk to it's
weird do mi talking do you like that
okay all right the other one oh ah sorry
actually I'm not sorry you deserve a
statue I don't trust you up
stay there [ __ ] there you go are
you happy you like that do you like that
like that
my throwing all right fine
can't do anything I need a drill where's
my drill that's my girl what the [ __ ] is
up with that box
oh no they drain my on the barrel stream
Jesus Christ what can you do I'm just a
man I obviously missed something
god damn it oh you're trapped forever
barrel like new feedback all right maybe
the Potteries or whatever that may be in
this forever how about this wrap bag no
keys no nothing why would you put a
drill in a party
I guess it makes sense if you think
really hard about it not too hard just
yard
that's not providing really hard come on
I need a drill yeah but the baby I need
to be e2b cannot use that net me why can
I go here it's a freakin Prison key do
you want please please let me in
why you know work no no no nothing hey
what about this what uh we never went
here did we you could have told me
instead of just sitting there sitting
there it's gotta be this thank God uh-oh
that's a cow never mind okay oh no oh no
they work together oh no I don't like
this alright fine
I picked out the tinderbox you got a
problem you got a problem I can move
cash huh you got a problem I think
you're tough on you say oh my god I
never know okay whatever
uh let's look out of your butt mmm I
like that cow vagina
that's lovely okay I'm in battle hey
okay I'm just gonna pull this lever and
is that the sound of him coming all
right it's no drill but I think we
progress it's good it's all good okay
now we can go here ah this guy's door
always open in my head hey tin mind
never use them how many I have twelve
any boxes I don't forget hey drags Laden
and then and then named oh look at this
box around the box what if you can do it
again
[Music]
about all right this progress I'm sorry
oh I like that huh be without you
without your cousin ha ha ha he's dead
now
battles your cousin is dead ah that's
it's gonna be something in here these
guys hey I not I think that Bauhaus you
can never trust them ever it's proven
that I mean it's for several I'm talking
about
all right this is real this
[ __ ] doubt that's really it
might if I can doubt all right go yeah
yeah that not puppies I'm know what's
going on it's loading all right that was
all laughing mice oh thanks for playing
that was a really good story by the way
it's like what the [ __ ] happened
should there be a part to let me know
what you think scripting everything
Torelli and yeah that was fun
really scary I think I got one of my
words jump scares ever in that amount in
the last episode if you didn't watch it
I hope you enjoyed leave a like and
favorite if you did subscribe to come a
brother day and I'll see you tomorrow
is it a deal is it a deal
[Music]
I
I think that what do you want from me a
mice hey there we go all right Oh